Josh Duggar is out of rehab GT can  exclusively report the embattled former  reality star has left his long-term  treatment facility a source close to the  Duggar family tells ET quote he has been  out for a few days in late August the  Duggars revealed that Josh had checked  into a long-term program so he was in  treatment for around six months total  they said at the time for him it will be  a long journey toward wholeness and  recovery we pray that in this he comes  to complete repentance and sincere  change the Duggar family faced serious  backlash last year after it came to  light that Josh had molested some of his  younger sisters when he was a teenager  and later that he had used the Ashley  Madison website at one point Duggar  admitted to cheating on his wife anna  anna has stayed close by the family side  while josh has been away it is such a  betrayal for a spouse to to go through  um what we're walking through and um it  was hard  you